boeing's beleaguered 737 max airliner
will be allowed to fly again
after the faa removed a grounding order
just this morning
now the jet has not flown passengers
since march of last year
after two deadly crashes linked to a
design flaw killed 346 people
and led to the worldwide grounding of
the plane chris van cleave is at reagan
national airport
right outside washington dc with more on
the story so chris when could the 737
max return to service
well good morning gail before the plane
can take off a couple of things have to
happen
airlines have to install the updates
that address the design issues with the
plane
and then pilots have to get additional
training including simulator time
but at least one u.s carrier says it
intends to fly the 737 max with
passengers
before the end of the year
the 737 max ungrounding order comes
after nearly 20 months of work
addressing a design flaw that led to two
deadly crashes just months apart
at the center of the redesign is the
mcas anti-stall system
linked to both accidents the changes
agreed upon by regulators from around
the world
add redundancy to the sensors that can
trigger mcas while limiting how that
system operates
so it should no longer be able to
overpower a flight crew
faa administrator steve dixon flew the
plane last month
we're going to make sure that the
process is completed correctly
the ungrounding is unwelcome news for
the families of the 346
killed in the max crashes passengers
should look to fly on a different plane
than the boeing 737 max michael stumo
lost his daughter on ethiopian 302.
there is not
yet enough redundancy and modernization
of the systems
to guard against a third yet a third
crash
boeing says the plane is safe and will
now be able to resume
deliveries the max is believed to
account for approximately one-third of
boeing's revenue over the next five
years
its grounding has cost the company an
estimated 20 billion dollars
how do you feel about getting behind the
controls of the airplane
once it goes back into service i'm
looking forward to flying the max
737 captain laura einsettler when you
see the experienced pilots coming on
board with confidence and in our
training and our mastery
and you can know that it's safe american
airlines says
it intends to resume 737 max passenger
service as soon as december 29th
on a single daily route between miami
and laguardia and back to miami
of course yet to be resolved flyer
feelings about
getting back on board the 737 max
anthony clearly critical to boeing's
bottom line chris but a lot of people
may be reluctant to get on board
thank you